al comenzar su visita de tres días en
este barrio obrero de marsella emanuel
mccone estaba ansioso por escuchar a los
residentes como este profesor de
educación trata en la educación los
jóvenes se están alejando de ella el
futuro de los jóvenes de marsella es el
tema central de la visita del presidente
francés el fracaso del sistema educativo
es sólo uno de los principales problemas
que afronta la ciudad junto con la
inseguridad y un transporte público de
segunda categoría aunque los sucesivos
gobiernos franceses han puesto sobre la
mesa grandes cantidades de dinero para
impulsar el desarrollo de marsella hasta
ahora no ha servido de nada el plan de
macrón implica miles de millones de
euros en ayudas aunque el martes
reconoció que la financiación por sí
sola no resolverá los problemas de la
ciudad no quiero tirar miles de millones
de euros porque ya se ha hecho muchas
veces hemos dicho antes y lo han visto
que no sabemos a dónde han ido a parar
esos miles de millones de urgente es que
nos ocupemos de la seguridad de las
escuelas y de la vivienda el plan del
gobierno de marsella se centra en gran
medida en la lucha contra la
delincuencia especialmente los barrios
del norte que son el epicentro del
tráfico de drogas de la ciudad portuaria
estas mujeres perdieron un hijo y un
sobrino en un asesinato relacionado
con una banda sólo este año ha habido 15
asesinatos de este tipo en marsella con
una víctima de tan sólo 14 años el
ministro del interior francés le ha
prometido añadir 300 agentes de policía
a la fuerza local para 2023 sin embargo
con las elecciones presidenciales de
francia sólo ocho meses de distancia
muchos en marsella argumentarán que
macrón tiene un ojo puesto en las urnas
la mayoría de la gente va a decir que
porque no ha hecho nada no ha esperado a
las elecciones para ver el problema de
marsella way
si hay una cuarta parte de los
marselleses vive por debajo del umbral
de la pobreza mientras que el 53 por
ciento de los hogares están exentos de
impuestos porque no pueden pagarlos la
deuda de la ciudad asciende actualmente
a 1500 millones de euros